um and then i guess we'll just talk
about the center one
there's a reason why i put it in the
center because i still think to this day
it's one of the greatest manga series
ever made it's the one manga series that
i know like i'm i'm building myself up
yeah it's like it's like i've watched
the last season of bojack horseman it's
not because i don't want to yeah i just
i'm just kind of not in the mindset
where i want to be depressed i mean you
know with your three by three right you
were talking about like the one that you
enjoyed the most and the one you think
is the best is different yeah yeah this
is definitely that the one that you
think i did not enjoy
know this even though i've never read it
it's one of those
series or stories from why i understand
that it's just it hits you and it sticks
with you and it's like you you read it
once and it's just a part of you i just
got like [ __ ] to do you know like i'm
gonna be sad for like a while yeah right
yeah i gotta deal with it i remember i i
binged this manga for the first time and
i went i finished reading at like four
am yeah and i just kind of the moment i
finished it i just kind of closed it and
just sat on my couch i know exactly
let's say me after every bojack episode
yeah and then they're like then they're
automatically playing the next one like
no no
give me some time
but i think i think the one thing that i
really like about oyster pimping is the
fact that it almost like it almost goes
beyond manga like what iniosano did an
oyster punch is so like we were talking
about metaphors before right with uh you
know i shall 21 stuff like that yeah the
metaphors in oyasumi poonpin are insane
because
literally like what kind of mangaka has
the balls to turn their main character
into a metaphor i think it's genius i
think it's absolutely genius so to
explain oysterme punt for those who
don't know
this is the main character his name is
punpun
um he's a bird character but and every
other character in the manga is a human
yeah but all the human characters see
poonpoon as a human it's okay so it's
like how he sees himself as different
it's how he sees himself but it's also
how you as the reader see him
as well so like throughout the manga as
he's got so basically it's this manga
where it follows this life of punpun
growing up so he starts off as a kid and
he turns into a teenager
i don't like the sound of this yeah i
don't like i don't like shows
i know it's gonna be [ __ ] and it kind
of very slowly yet steadily it goes
through every inch of his
life there's a lot of things that happen
to him and around him that are very
[ __ ] yeah that's how it looks yeah
yeah so like you know it starts off with
him as a kid he meets this girl
you know learns what falling in love is
right learns the the the joys and the
heartbreak of puberty and then again i
feel you man and then that drags on with
him and then he has family problems he
has problems with his friends he has
problems with basically just just a
broken life you know it's a broken life
and what's so brilliant about oyster
punk is that as obviously you know like
when he like gets older he's he gets
bigger and taller but still the bird
but then there are certain points in the
manga where his look completely changes
so there's one part in the manga where
he just turns into a floating pyramid
for about two chapters oh okay and it's
not really explain why
it happens but as you're reading
metaphor context yeah it represents
something in here okay and it's very and
it's very literal
how long is it how many chapters is
seven volumes i own it's all of them
yeah i've owned all of them for years
it's been city it's twelve volumes i
think okay well 120 like [ __ ] okay so i
own seven of them
well no i believe at least the
translated volume yeah the western
volumes are a lot thicker yeah yeah
they're a lot thicker so i have i only
have 13 volumes in japan but it's like
120 something chapters oh so you could
probably read it in one day you could
easily written i mean i read it in one
day like it's it's been sitting on my
shelf i think for years it's just been
staring me and i'm like i stare at it
and i'm just like it's today the day
it's today i've read it
my very first experience with hearing
about yes me pinpoint was actually like
when i first started dating sydney and
uh
so i um this was when i back when i
didn't know sydney too well and she gets
really really invested in stories right
and stories she's one of you know one of
those people that you know gets truly
gets invested and involved into a piece
of fiction
um so i'm just here sitting and sitting
in my room sitting in my office doing
like youtube videos or whatever um and
then i hear sydney just like bawling i
mean this is like this is like i'd never
seen her cry harder than this yeah like
she was like like beyond ugly crying you
know it was like i came in and like mike
was wrong
my god just sang because like i've only
like this is the kind of reaction you
see when someone's family member just
died you know and um i'm just like i
take a few deep breaths i'm like okay i
know i know we're gonna have to deal
with something serious something's
really [ __ ] up and i'm just like
honey are you okay what happened she
just went
i just finished a manga and i know and i
did ash just went
what
and she's like
what's going on
and i'm just like
i i am going back in my office now i
hate some clinics
but yeah like i
i i mean like i didn't like ugly solve
at the end of pun pun but yeah i i there
were definitely moments throughout pune
that
i kind of just opened my eyes wide and i
was like holy [ __ ] like there were many
times where i actually said to myself
out loud i was like no
no
they're not like this no it's not like
this
and it's like and again it's like it's
the way that he can somehow fit this
[ __ ] bird character into a super
realistic context of like very realistic
setting with very realistic characters
yeah and give this bird this the most
human life possible is so insane to me
and the fact that he can just do it
seamlessly like you know obviously at
first if you're going into this blind
yeah first couple of pages you're like
what the [ __ ] is this
what what the [ __ ] is this bird
yeah but you kind of like learn to grow
with it and again like you know it's
it's one of those things where like a
lot of people say like oh he turned it
into a bird so that you yourself can put
yourself into punpin's situation
yeah so that if you're not fixated on
one particular type of person you know
when concerning looks and stuff like
that like you can just imagine this is
any human
and it's just yeah and again it's like
ini osano literally just took all these
like
rudimentary concepts about manga and
just went
through out the window and just went i'm
just gonna draw what i think is cool
and it's like there's lots of like weird
[ __ ] in it as well but like
i mean i've been trying to write a video
about this manga for so long but
literally every time i reread it first
of all i get destroyed for about a week
so i try not to do it but second of all
there's just so many subtle things in it
that i keep picking up on that i didn't
before that just completely makes me
change the way i view this manga and
it's just yeah it's insane
so like again probably the manga i
enjoyed the least yeah yeah but
definitely one of the best yeah in my
mind
that's what i assumed it was going to be
which is just like i'm not reading this
manga to enjoy it i'm reading this manga
because i know it's probably going to be
one of the most
like powerful pieces of media i've ever
consumed and that's that's like my
assumption going into it and the final
chapter made me cry like [ __ ] crazy i
was like [ __ ] man